[Music]
yes
now we are allowed to drive off okay now
we can go as fast as we want I 174 185
193 okay this is fast and I've been
lines 91 we have speed limit we don't
have the speed limit why is there a
speed limit here there are a few bumps
in the road so I hope I have only 100
but when we see a sign what is it say I
should say go for it
Thomas no it's just open go for it punch
it punch it Mars yes I just had an
orgasm we do a hundred azzam oh no I
thought it well your orgasm is so
efficient to Germany's styling
to
I've been crazy near bars bars yeah
third place like the air and in this
part it's for me to make me 50p because
I just did okay this is a very fast I
think we have fifty but do you ever sing
songs when you drive Garrick another son
99 bottles of beer on the wall
you know that song it's an American song
okay you mind if I sing our singing in
German singing singing yes and I know
noisy flash of beer on your mouth no an
annoyance in fashion girl
me neither on tour I see room Hong Kong
see fashion beer of your mouth no I
don't in same fashion beer after power
no I know things are flushing beer that
make sense to you that's all
no but it sounds the way you you took
your hands off but you can take them off
through quad me